joining us on the telephone from new
zealand in new zealand
is dr talib mao jude who was attending a
conference in christchurch at the time
of the massacre
he has visited one of the two mosques
that were attacked and knows several
people
who would have been praying inside dr
mao jude good morning and
first our condolences and sympathies to
you and your community
uh good morning uh i appreciate your
thoughts and your sympathies
it is a difficult time for us and it's
good to hear that you're supporting us
doctor tell me about uh the feeling
inside with your family and
in the community in the wake of this
awful tragedy
the feeling is one of shock this is
something that
no one in new zealand has been
emotionally prepared for
this kind of hatred and violence is
completely foreign to all new zealanders
um it's something that we're
unfortunately accustomed
uh to hear from other parts of the world
that
we never would have dreamed in our worst
nightmares that it would happen here in
new zealand
and to those that are close to us
you were near the the mosque when the
shooting occurred what did you see in
here
and we're also hearing that you had been
planning to go to that mosque is that
true
this is true the mosque was
one that i've visited many times over
over the years nearly by chance that i
escaped
you know that was that i was not
involved
you know clearly if things had been just
slightly different i
i would have been in respect of it
doctor
describe what what prayers would have
been like yesterday if you'd been to the
mosque
the prayers on a friday afternoon are
um the most
widely attended of any of the prayers of
the week
it's the equivalent of sunday mass i
guess
and uh the attendance usually are
several hundred hundred um the the
the halls are typically completely
packed um
and uh it's it's you know people
uh worshipping and peacefully um
shoulder to shoulder and um to have that
disrupted
in such a violent way it's just
terrifying it's
a horrifying thought did you know anyone
that was injured doctor
uh yes uh unfortunately um
uh i have um a family friend who
you know we've known because for many
years whose wife um
unfortunately were succumbed to injuries
uh from the gunshot wounds um and we
know others that
that that escaped unscathed so it is
it is close to harm all right dr tully
mao jude
thank you and again our sympathies and
we wish you a speedy and safe return to
your family
thank you thank you very much good
speaking with you